ein super leckeres Spargelrezept in nur
20 Minuten den Spargel am besten in
mundgerechte Stücke schneiden dann eine
Zwiebel fein hacken die Butter in einer
Pfanne schmelzen und die Zwiebel 3 bis 4
Minuten anbraten jetzt das Mehl
dazugeben und kurz mit anschwitzen mit
Wasser und Milch ablöschen und dann die
Soße mit gemüsebrühpaste mit Salz
Pfeffer Muskat und Zitronensaft würzen
und den weißen Spargel dazugeben hier
aber noch vorsichtig die Spargelköpfe
nicht mit dazu geben weil die eine
kürzere Garzeit haben das ganze darf
dann jetzt etwa 8 bis 12 Minuten lang
köcheln in der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr
gerne Nudeln kochen oder auch
Pfannkuchen zubereiten anschließend die
Spargelköpfe mit dazugeben dann am Ende
mit Nudeln servieren in Pfannkuchen
einrollen oder anderweitig genießen
[Musik]